today I come home from a 370 two-day  deployment my soon-to-be fiance has no  idea yet when on my first date in over  three hundred days with my soldier  tonight take that deployment best  Christmas present I got one year was my  dad coming home from Iraq I'm coming  home to surprise my soon-to-be wife  after being deployed for two years  my dad just returned from his very last  deployment he is deployed overseas eight  different times my family and I can  finally live a normal life with him here  with us and I've never been so happy I'm  a u.s. Marine and my family has no idea  I'm on my way home my mom doesn't know  we're actually on her way to pick up my  dad who's been deployed for months I'm  coming home tomorrow after seven months  of deployment I'm surprising my  girlfriend and proposing to her she has  no idea I'm coming back I came home  early to surprise my mom for her  birthday it's impossible to watch just  one soldier surprise homecoming happy  tears every time